ريش طير حقيقي علق على الرؤوس واقنعه
مرعبه تغطي الوجوه وصوت اجراس تدق بحركات
رقص غريبه هذه المشاهد ليست من كواليس في
المرام انما مهرجان لطرد الشياطين في
بلغاريا
[موسيقى]
هنا في احدى قرى مدينه كوشاريفو غرب
بلغاريا خرج المواطنون في ليله حالكه
ليحتفل بطقوس مهرجان يعود لمئات السنين
ويقام كل سنه في شهر يناير ويعرف بمهرجان
سورفا لطرد الشياطين
المشاركون في طقوس المهرجان يعرفون باسم
سورفا كارث يرتدون اقنعه وازياء تنكريه
مصنوعه يدويا وتختلف الازياء في المهرجان
كل عام ففي هذه السنه مثلا كان زي احمر
اللون باجراس ربطت على البطون وليش طير
حقيقي علق على الرؤوس
اما في عام 2019 كنزي اشبه بكره شعر كبيره
تتحرك هذا زي تنكري ذكرنا بموضوع تحدثنا
عنه سابقا وكان حول سحره الفودو في دوله
بنين وزيهم الذي تشابه مع زي مهرجان سورفا
ببلغاريا
كومه قش يقلبها سحره الفودو قليلا لحظات
من الانتظار ضربات خفيفه تصحو الكوم
وتتحرك وترقص ترقص هنا على انغام الطبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لنعد الان الى موضوعنا فالطقوس في هذه
القريه تستمر ليومين وتبدا من الصباح
وتنتهي في الليل وتتنوع النشاطات فيها من
رقص وقفز وتقديم قرابين يؤمن فيها السكان
المحليون بانها تبعد الارواح الشريره
وتقيهم من المصائب وتجلب لهم فصل الربيع
بالبهجه والازدهار
فيما تشهد ليله المهرجان طقوسا اغرب حيث
تضرم النيران وسط ساحه يحيط بها السكان ثم
يبدا المشاركون بالرقص والدوران حولها
بطريقه غريبه
المهرجان في الدوله الواقعه في منطقه
البلقان شهد عام 2019 مشاركه قياسيه حيث
بلغ عدد المحتفلين حوالي 7500 قادمين من
تسع دول لكنه توقف عام 2020 بسبب فيروس
كورونا وعاد عام 2021 ليستمر البلغاريون
في احيائي هذا التقليد السنوي